Trump's saying that now it's actually
hard to say DeSantis because he's gotten
so used to using the nicknames for
DeSantis Rhonda sanctimonious by 56 69
for Trump 13 for the Sanctus
and Pence has six you know once you get
used to saying to scientists it's hard
to say to Santos I was actually being
interviewed and I was trying to be
serious and I called them the Sanctus I
said that's not good but he's changing
his name you know now it's DeSantis
and I put a little message out never
change your name in the middle of a
campaign
I have to admit that actually is funny
it seems one of the stupidest things you
can do if you're trying to get name
recognition is pronounce your name two
different ways DeSantis and D Santas
Trump trump actually in the midst of all
the legal chaos able to put together a
little kernel of good political advice